prendre
en main
oui je parle la bouche pleine parce que
chez bigot qui comprennent ce langage
mais parce que je vais à la pâtisserie
chocolaterie bigot qui est une
institution qui régale les amboisiens et
aujourd'hui c'est moi quel régal
[Musique]
je connais cet endroit
ce rappel a dit l'oncle
[Musique]
oh
ap
[Musique]
bonjour questionne impressionnant
bonjour comment la médaille pour
commencer mettez-moi 5 nounours guimauve
je vais prendre également dit boucher à
choisir une boîte complète de paula la
boîte entière de amboise in recommande
vous les mettez tout tous les goûts tous
les arômes et bien sûr les rochers et
finirait par des muscats dean complète
mettez-moi toutou voilà je veux
découvrir la puissance de la boulangerie
bigot parce que sa date depuis 1913
depuis 1913 avec mon grand-père qui a
fondé la maison c'est un homme qui
aimait travailler pendant cinquante ans
et ça mais derrière ce succès il ya des
femmes ça commence par julia c'est elle
qui tient les comptes à l'époque avec
des cosses école chez hermès était pour
faciliter la tenue des comptes les
boulangers de l'école de l'époque au
dessus de la caisse avait une fille
celle à laquelle étaient accrochés des
baguettes de noisetiers avec le nom du
client et quand le client pr nuit libre
de pain puisque c'était souvent comme ça
on fait une coach se pose et à la fin
quand la coach eddy baigne le client
paye et quelle a été la transformation
en 1973 alors en 73 toute la partie
fournie il a été transformé en salon de
thé mais y avait déjà un salon t au
début du siècle avec quatre tables
quelques est tout petit prix les assauts
on va les voir paula paula comment on se
sent quand on hérite d'un patrimoine
familial comme celui là et même un
patrimoine historique on s'en bat
justement famille que j'ai grandi j'ai
grandi ici ma hauteur de vitré de
gâteaux et il ya même des ateliers si on
peut se former pour apprendre à faire du
chocolat oui grégoire anime des ateliers
là depuis un peu plus d'un an avec des
clients qui veulent s'initier au
chocolat
et voilà la chocolaterie avec grégoire
mai
ce trio puis 2019 ici comme ça fait deux
ans cette année et oui on a mis les
ateliers en place l'année dernière avec
paul annacone pour faire des pouvoirs
aux gens de métier de chocolatier
alors aux ateliers g soit des familles
entières qui viennent beaucoup de
couples des enfants et sinon après des
gens qui m'aident en spontané entre amis
avec des gens qui se rencontrent aux
essais aux ateliers ou des fois des
groupes entiers qui privatise pour toute
une famille et toute une bande d'amis
un jour quand je recherchais un poste
quand j'avais un petit peu moment c'est
l'entreprise gg postulants spontanée et
quelques mois plus tard m'a répondu pour
une phase de chocolatines
[Musique]
oui c'est une deuxième langue qu'on
apprend à l'école et au développement
d'entreprises sont touchés bibeau
on
et
où
bon
[Musique]